wow what a massive audience thank you
it's awesome I was talking to a friend
yesterday and he kept on asking like
okay but your workshop and your talks
what do they have to do with dotnet and
c-sharp I tried to explain it they're
not he came up but yeah but what do they
have to do with c-sharp
I said no so this is not really the C++
conference so um apologies if you wish
we're going to talk about an idea that I
had in 2012 and something that happened
since
so I presented the idea and the funniest
thing happened the years later I looked
on my Wikipedia page yes I have a wiki
up Wikipedia page friends so I was
looking at my API page which I never do
anything with I never participated and
just let people go so essentially
there's a guy who deleted everything
I've done from Wikipedia and there was
one thing left which was Andre invented
the expected type that's the only thing
on Wikipedia probably right now that I
did and so I thought I should give a
talk about it because it seems to be of
the last bastion of things that I've
done that I've are interesting to people
so what happened was after I presented
this this idea in in 2012 one fine
German Jean Francois Bastian he took it
and ran with it he was very nice to give
me credit to but essentially he took he
did all the legwork which is real not
like 95% of the work to standardize it
so as of right now what we're talking
about is being proposed for
standardization for C+ was 20 so you
know this talk might have might be more
applicable in the near future than
than it may seem ok so we're going to
start with discussing exceptions who's a
fan yes like it's okay who's coding C++
starting with a couple of us don't okay
who hates exception exceptions
exceptions suck man the same people
right okay so the left hand votes that
way right hand goes the other way
awesome so most of us you know when I
read about the exceptions quite
literally my for my next like you know
five thousand lines of code they all had
a try-catch in there there's all the
functions I wrote oh my god so awesome
and try and catch and they become blue
in the editor now so jazz the body oh my
god is the key word so I get to do try
and catch and catch things and throw
things and that was awesome but I took
them for for the most part all of this
exception business for me it was well
this is the feature you gotta use it
going forward and it was very unclear to
me what would be the motivation of
exceptions and how do they came about
like how come it's all about this
throwing catch and stack unwinding on
all of this nonsense right so what we're
going to do right now is we're going to
start from P universe without exceptions
and we're going to slowly figure out
what it takes to handle errors
non-locally if you wish and we're going
to get to a model of exceptions that is
pretty much the the proposed model the
existing model so first of all like I
press the okay great have this new
remote which does this about that
alright so what would be a proper proper
baseline so what do you compare except
some exceptions against a Zener handling
mechanism right what are the design
goals what are the use cases how do
their semantics support these use cases
as etc so I'm sure most of us in this
room do have a notional you know they
have some some some perception some some
ideas about
to answering these questions so let's
move on to considering the exceptions so
you know the base the core definition of
an exception it would be an exceptional
case the problem with this definition is
what's exceptional really depends a lot
on the context is by in exceptional is
by definition subjective because what's
exception is not normal what is normal
the norm what is not norm something that
we encounter all day long right it's
sort of the average is the you know the
the run-of-the-mill situation so I've
been working on systems in which things
that would be considered normal
exceptional were not being organ systems
such as machines interconnected via via
a very very solid interconnect and if
there's the two machines are not
communicating that would be of as bad as
the RAM not working so in that case
opening a file or communicating when
opening a socket to the other machine
would have been an exceptional case
similarly something that would be
considered a normal normal thing
otherwise would be exceptional in these
other systems etc so depending on the
situation you may consider exceptional
things different by the you know atom
like person whom so you know Alan Perlis
he he's sort of the father of computing
funny one-liners and he said famously
that one man's constant is another man's
variable so what do we want from an
exception system that error handling in
general that is that is palatable we
want to learn it once and use many times
we don't to have many mechanisms say
they'll open a parenthesis right here
sadly in c-plus we have quite a few ways
of finding errors and more are coming by
which is a sign to me that people are
not really super happy with what's going
on right now
who knows about herb satis latest
proposal all right so I'm in the right
crowd here so I'm seeing a pair Apache
there of people who are like yeah
you know know so we want to minimize
soft airs and maximize the Harder's and
what's softer what's a heart there who
can as I'm taking this turn from
reliability from from reliability theory
if you wish what would be a software a
software is not discovered immediately a
hardware is discovered as soon as it
happens you can have a you can have
detection so what would be an example of
a software and c++ Thank You dangling
pointer you said it yesterday too so a
dangling pointer would be a great
example because he just sits there and
the program I even continued running
almost correctly until he doesn't write
and you know all the demon asel demons
and stuff those of you who've been
yesterday in the tsipras's meetup
organized by by Pat here so you know Adi
gave a great great talk and part of it
was a function that was never called
that will remove everything from her
drive and even though it was ostensibly
never called it was called and it was it
would remove everything from her drive
simply because the the C++ a model of
computation considers all behavior
defined and by that you know considers
that the behavior of any given program
is defined and does optimizations based
on that assumption and then whenever you
have undefined behavior it's going to
you know really odd things are going to
happen now you know we want to minimize
these softwares we want to have as few
software's as possible that you know
it's a bad the software is a bad thing
you know in a reliable system we want to
maximize the hard does you detect them
as soon as they happen
another thing that we want would be to
allow centralized but also local
handling right and I'm sure you can
figure out some assistance for handing
girls are good at local hanging
immediately right there you test an
error code real quick right and the
others would be you know better
centralized error handling which is I
throw from everywhere
catch in one place right by the way by
show of hands how many of you think what
is okay now how do i phrase this what is
the ideal ratio of throws two catches 1
to 1 or less 0 to 0 0 to 0 is correct no
matter what okay
10 to 1 ten throws for each one catch
all right 100 to 1 1000 to 1 or more
all right thank you so we have a few
opinions I think I have no idea but I
think that there's no answer to this but
I do I do think and a lot of people
agree that you need to have in a good
application a bunch of throws but only a
handful of caches because exceptions are
designed specifically for handling
errors in in a centralized fashion as
opposed to in a local in a local manner
right but we want both because sometimes
you want that sometimes you want the
other so you want a flexible system and
that's what we're going to aim for this
this talk we want to be able to
transport an arbitrary keep on we want
to transport this arbitrary amount of
very information from the from the throw
side to the castle from whenever there
happened to wherever there is going to
be detected and handled so that's an
interesting thing we would like to have
and we want to have a little cast on the
normal path which we're going to discuss
a bit today and of course we want to
make correct code easy to write
incorrect or difficult to write though I
I think we're in agreement about this
list of the I have a dream right great
exhibit number a your honor
members of the jury I'm sure the a to I
function which is I mean you know let's
let's give it credit it's like probably
the first function in the C programming
language ever invented right so it's a
it's an epitome of poor error handling
the problem is a 2y is in case of error
in case anything bad happens doing parts
in the string it will return 0 thank you
which just so happens to be the most
frequent valid number right so then if
8y retail you call 8y you get 0 so then
you need to kind of figure out was it a
real 0 string or not the problem being
the actual string 0 but also the actual
string with whitespace preceding 0 also
the string that has white space followed
by a plus or minus sign followed by 55
zeroes if I wish followed by another
million spaces because I can that's also
valid 0 so it turns out that the parsing
the deciding whether a to I was right
you know
encountered an error or not is almost as
difficult as implementing 8y itself time
I'm not gonna renounce this joke no
matter how much you don't laugh okay I'm
not gonna so another problem with a 2y
which is also very interesting is that
8y is what's called in math a surjective
function and I summon thee to come back
from the drunkenness of your college
years and tell me what the subjective
function is what is it okay you're
really drunk everybody ìiíd what he
fainted he rose he was like I was just
actually yes it can have many different
inputs and a single output no f-
okay any yes please the range equals the
domain meaning whatever whatever code
domain the function has you know the
possible values values of the output
they're gonna be covered there's gonna
be at least one value in the input
that's going to cover the output right
which means you can't reserve a
particular value of an int to say well
this particular int is a pariah so I'm
going to say whenever there's an R I'm
gonna return a pariah that does happen
with floating-point numbers because we
have nan thank you very much that can
happen with pointers because we have now
that could happen with strings can you
happen with strings is there a string
that's a pariah no an empty string would
be a valid valid string but I know a
string that never ever nobody ever ever
has been in which and that would be your
prior string that returned in case of
her don't do that I was kidding okay so
um a try being a suggestion can preserve
a variance say you know whatever so you
know now just as a as a side remark
there is an integer which is a semi
pariah what what is your least favorite
integer
I mean int not integer int in the you
know like 32-bit end what is your least
favorite 32-bit end - one - one is very
nice mean int why would be you can't
stay you can't - it and get something
positive a bunch of code that seems that
if you if X less than 0 X gets minus X
and they're like yes X is positive now
except 1 is the minimum integer the you
know the most negative integer so that's
a problem which when you write library
code it's really unpleasant because you
gotta pay attention to this kind of
nonsense right so anyway
hy would be a good example of a function
that you know it has a number of issues
related to error handling and I gotta
add the following
in 8y there's two kinds of verse that
may happen you may try to convert a
string that's not a number but you may
also try to convert the string that is
too large a number and these are
different errors you know you may have a
string of digits that don't fit in an
integer and many early implementation of
it too I forgot about that so they
simply like they just go through the
input and overflow the integer and they
just return in some nonsense right all
right so let's discuss a bit about or no
like there no love there no right so
yeah I'm seeing like some sneakers in
the room so area is general but it
doesn't mean my software's because
pretty much nobody's looking at it ever
it allows for centralized handing can do
a bunch of stuff and then look at there
no it'll also look and Hanley do one
thing and look at there no you can
execute an arbitrary cannot sorry cannot
transport an arbitrary amount of error
information from wherever it happens to
whatever wherever you are and that's a
power because you know there's a kind of
a crowding of error codes in operating
systems they keep on trying to allocate
new New York codes and you kind of skim
out of for like divine I don't think if
this bit is whatever this happened so
very pleasant when your user and you
want to add your own error codes and
their get printed as I don't know filer
or whatever I or so it's a bummer I
don't think I need to insist that
turn-on would not be the best would not
be the flagship that we work on from now
on right agreed thank you very much all
right don't be a special value solution
which we discussed already problem you
know the main problem is it's not
generally enough to be considerable
considered there's simply no there are
simply types with no no unique sorry no
singleton values no singular I meant to
say values so pointers are good because
there's null and there's also a pointer
minus one
did you know down the pointer minus one
if you do memory-mapped i/o in linux
that there's there are a number of
functions that return you the pointer -
one you actually need to check because
it's a it's a different error than if it
returns null now I'm not kidding this is
what we have yeah not that joke don't
don't ok so I make jokes people say like
whatever and then okay so with the
special value it's I'm sure everybody
knows that the trade-offs involved and
everything so you know I can't transport
whatever information I need and it's
kind of a bummer it looks ad hoc and
it's not a general solution right we
would have a solution that requires us
to pass in the you know the I want to
pass in a sort of a pointer to the error
information and the system fills it this
is very common in now in places like
Windows API right in Windows you very
often whenever you want to receive an
error code you cannot pass a pointer to
an integer whatever and it feels it for
you with their code if if you asked for
it
also like the the C standard library has
the string to long function which takes
a string but also takes this fine
gentleman here do you know what it does
by the way C is like that you know it
should be in the Guinness Book of
Records because he has the most
functions for converting integer strings
to integers in the world there's a - I
ate - I - you well you know it -
whatever which are all bad right and
then it has a string - long string -
long son long string - whatever
and then it has a scan F and F scan F
and then it has a massive even if there
are or are around or wherever standard
ecv T does this ring a bell okay we are
old my friend you and I are old so what
you gonna do okay this fine parameter
here e is passing by the user and filled
by by the function itself with a pointer
to recall this is a double pointer I'm
allowed to do double pointer this is a
C++ doc not a c-sharp talk for those of
you can hit in the wrong place here so
you pass in a pointer to a pointer to
character and the function fills it with
wherever the conversion stopped and then
it leaves it to you to divine whatever
the hell happened right it's like whoa
so am I here right so usually you want
to be on the 0 character which would be
the last you know past the end of the
string meaning the whole string has been
converted R will be the the radix and by
the way the radix can be as big as 32
because it yeah because it is like the
lower case and upper case letters okay
right so I'm happy to teach string too
long from 45 years ago and four months
so how about exceptions given that we
have our list to begin with let us again
this is a universe without exception so
we're free to invent syntax and stylize
things a bit just for the time being
right so let's talk about some like well
I have some invalid invalid input class
which contains whatever information I
want to pass about this function failing
and then I have something like well how
about I return an int or an invalid
input so this or here would would
signify a sort of some type of variant
right who knows what variants and some
title a few of us so well some time is
like it's either this guy or the other
guy and you know that the name of the
some type would be the name is earned by
virtue of the type being able to encode
everything that I mean has plus
everything that an invalid input or
whatever the other guy is all right so
it's the sum of the possible states so
that's a variant right so in our you
know in our fledgling system of handling
errors we're gonna have to return either
an int or some other thing that happened
that you know that prevented me from
reducing that hint and all is good and
dandy and then I'm going to do some sort
of a type switch notice I made it blue
because it would be a sort of a pseudo
keyword and then I pattern match against
the some type and I say well was it the
first branch of the second branch and if
it's the right branch and I'm going to
that's the happy case and otherwise is
the unhappy case so you know you can
read all about it
algebraic types and you know in the STD
variant and boost variant and all that
good stuff now of course this is kind of
hopelessly local and it's kind of weird
and one thing that I don't like is that
we you know the the previous syntax here
I turn back a bit so the previous syntax
here gives almost equal importance to
the end and to the invalid input when
didn't we agree that we have some sort
of happy case int rare exceptional
unhappy case invalid input so they
should be distinguished more than just
that they are equally possible in a
variant so this of the some types
technology is not really what we're
looking for what we're looking for is
some sort of unexpected versus
unexpected Millia vocabulary right right
I expect an int but if you know come
hell or high water something else might
be returned right so they need to be
distinguished syntactically and
semantically as expected versus
unexpected very saying here here's a at
this point 36 minutes in here you know
so at this very point this talk becomes
interesting right this is like a long
bath tonight
I'm trying folks I'm trying so you know
because until now all we've done was to
set up the stage just kind of say ah you
know what's uh you know what would
happen if and that kind of you know so
from now on we're starting to get into
something new and not that doesn't exist
anymore yet that were just not as much
inventing as discovering the interesting
distinction here is that we're not being
smart we're just starting with our list
of the nice things we want and then we
pull on that string and by means of
simple reasoning we get to some artifact
as opposed to our we're so clever we're
gonna do something really smart that
nobody nobody expects and this is
awesome so we discover more than we
invent something right it's a
consequence more than more than
something as surprising so local code
should be able to work was the ignoring
invalid input because that would be
centralized error handling so I should
assume the happy case and just code my
way out and then if anything bad happens
there should be a mechanism to to take
care of that so part by consequence the
function has an over return types plus
one or more cover return return type so
now I say one or more it means because
that particular function may call other
functions that in turn choose to have
their own covert return types and the
next natural question would be word do
all of these hidden covert return values
go what's their deal well it turns out
they need to have their own their own
flow of control because they can't be
handled by the happy case because the
happy case is not prepared to handle
them right it's simple deduction right
this time nothing up my sleeves friends
I'm really not David Copperfield here
right I'm not inventing anything so
covert virus must return somewhere you
know somewhere to some some color that
is able to handle those particular
exceptional cases and only certain
course understands their nerve some
don't indeed so there's there's a sort
of a search process if you wish for a
color that knows how to handle the my
particular exceptional case so that
means covert return types come with
covert execution pass each with
potentially its own and the callers must
plan somehow return points
electing such types so here we are we
just invented exceptions friends they
are consequence as much as a terrible
invention I'm using the silence for an
effect here to let it sink in okay so we
get to a pipe base first much exception
handling let me add one little detail
first match is an interesting decision
for C++ and for all object-oriented
languages because all our
object-oriented languages always go for
best match who can give us an example of
best match in object-oriented languages
when does the language choose the best
match for you
overloading best match thank you but
that would be more like C++ because some
object-oriented languages are not very
strong at overloading so even more yeah
overriding so it's going to always pick
the you know when color method is going
to find the most derived version of the
method yes thank you very much the most
specialized as they say other ideas from
the C++ world
come on templates write in templates you
always choose the best match the combine
has the soul this whole partial ordering
business and it's always going whenever
there's some templates kind of hanging
out you know having a smoke and a beer
and whatever I think is gonna say you
are the best match you go to the
military right that's so that's the
thing it's only the best match however
exception by the way that's not good or
bad it's just there it's an
object-oriented thing in function
languages is the exact opposite and if
you have if you talk to a functional guy
they're gonna hate you because they can
say first match is the best match and
you say well I have the power of
language with me best match is the best
match and it just works right come on
it's in the name best match is the best
match known they say the first match is
the best match because in all function
languages you're going to see that the
first function match is going to be
called so it matters in which order
define your your functions interesting
so why is it first match in exception
handling any ideas speed I think it has
to do with the fact that you you you
move up the stack and essentially the
first person able to hand to handle that
or anything like it is going to be a
good match for for the exception right
awesome so exceptions aftermath so
they're fairly general it's unclear
whether the minimize of terms people
keep keep on making these having these
memory leaks whenever exceptions are
thrown but you know we as a community
community are getting a lot better it
they're designed for centralized
handling they are not good at all at
local handling and that's a problem
friends right so this will pretty much
the only read definitely read line or
you know read bullet point on our slide
here they are law transporting any
amount of our information they have a
little cost on the normal path famous
last words
what is the cost of exceptions when they
are not thrown 0 0 more than 0 what is
it give me a number
40 kilobytes right so but that just for
one exception or one catch sight ok all
right so 40 kilobytes may be still
important in some applications but I
told you about runtime costing at in
terms of time do exceptions make your
code smaller as slower even if never
thrown this is the question yes no other
thoughts yes
thank you so the answer was the compiler
must generate code in a different manner
when exception started when the spectrum
of exceptions is present because it
needs to generate prologue and epilogue
standardized for each function and it
also needs to make sure that whenever
exception is thrown the appropriate
cleanup code is executed right and that
major limits the optimizations that the
compiler can do which is essential one
is called motion the compilers in non
exceptional code let's say see straight
line code they're going to be able to do
code motion which means you know more
fragments of code around for maximum
performance and whenever you have
exceptions this is not possible anymore
because there's you know there's
restrictions on what the code can be
moved right if you look at the generated
code in any function you're going to see
that actually placing no except to the
function and all the function it calls
may have a dramatic impact on the
generated code dramatic and no except is
not you know is no basket of fruit
either because if you do put no except
and you throw you can still do that and
that is undefined behavior thank you
very much and that removes all of your
files on your drive as Adi sure that's
last night so not perfect so it's
unclear whether exceptions make correct
code easy to write I would say that it
took us literally 20 years as a
community to even so even to ask
ourselves the right questions but I
think there's a lot of progress herp has
done a lot of good work on sort of
proselytizing proper he has this
exceptional C++ books and he has a lot
of blog posts that followed on how to
write correct code in the presence of
exceptions and one
the things he recommends and which is
pretty awesome is you don't want to have
like raw pointers in your called raw
data and whatnot in your own class
definitions you want to have like you
know shared pointers or unique pointers
or whatnot that take care of their own
destruction and then whenever the
destructor of the class runs is going to
appropriately destroy all of the
components so that's nice because it
makes it makes exceptions take care of
exceptional situations a lot a lot
better so today we're going to focus on
the remaining redline so this is a you
know this my point here local handling
will be our focus going forward
so um the issues we have with exceptions
regard regarding local ER handling is
that error handling
when done loca is very symmetric it's
very heavy on the syntax side is very
difficult to look at and difficult to
maintain so let's take a look at
something of interest we're going to
implement a scheme that allows local
handling with exceptions but allow me to
start with a couple of background items
we've discussed a bit of this already
STD variant or boost variant or
sometimes and they give equal importance
all members which we don't like optional
is an interesting artifact lots about
stood optional boost optional it's
either something or nothing so it has
the dead boolean that tells you that you
know it's nothing in database
terminology that would be Nala bald data
right so any column can be like whatever
floating-point number or null which
means there's no value present at all
right but you know option is not good
because we want we don't option we want
not a value or nothing we want a value
or the exception that prevented this
vary from being produced right you see
why I'm going with this so I'm going
with these technologies are very close
to being needed but are not really
exactly what we want even the sort of
the monadic world
which may be an either which mimic which
are mimicked by if you wish busted
variant instead optional they would not
be exactly appropriate for us so we need
to do our own by the way another related
technology would be promising future in
C++ no bottom they come from the you
know multi-threading world and
essentially it's it's again it's
painfully close to what we need because
it's it's either you know promise of T's
either T or it gives the exception that
prevent the T from being returned here
however we want eager and synchronous
handling of these cases so let's define
a simple plus either actually that would
be expected so this kind of historical a
bit and we would have either a T or a
new place in a Union and we have a pool
that tells me whether it's a T or not so
that would be my Union type and now we
define expected which takes two template
arguments the first is the type that is
the happy case and the second is the
exception that may be produced if the
happy case didn't happen right so we
want to express the union of an over
type and a covert type so it's almost
like a variant but it gives asymmetric
importance to the two branches right so
in the normal case the value of is value
of type T is there in in the bad case of
value of type E is there and he has
extra information about what happened
and E would be constructed by the
function that returns it and read by the
receiver of the function so an expected
te would be either a t or my dog ate my
homework
yes it's either the homework or the dog
sorry or the excuse thank you yes so
it's either you know so that would be
typically returned from functions notice
that nothing has been thrown we're not
talking about throwing anything yet
please hands off the triggers okay we're
not throwing anything we are returning
only and we're returning these that you
know the slightly larger and more
elaborate values than we otherwise would
be returning but the benefit is that we
get to pass around information that
completely describes the computation
either at T has has been computed or
there was some reason for not being able
to compute it and there's no people
there's a there's an e doesn't there's a
there's a an excuse that if you wish
e-excuse awesome
so now redesigning a to Y if you wish
we're going to write something like
expected of ant and some error type er R
and that's my a to Y and if you want
local you're going to look the result
has value or result error whatever
and the typical idiom is if result use
the result the way this works is the
expected type we're gonna see in a
minute the expected type is going to
define primitives for testing with if
and you know as the cool way of you know
that C++ 1x wave you don't implement
operator bull right what is the C++
awesome way of implementing I want to be
testable with if explicit thank you very
much I have the illusion that everybody
knows and you're like you know what
we're not gonna say anything let him let
him sweat under the color there don't
care
so yes implant explicit operator bull
and that makes it is testable but not
convertible to bull implicitly which has
all of the liabilities that we know
about so if result used and then we have
the star result star result would be
dereference the result expecting an t it
affecting the happy case okay so box I
disagree with this design decision I'm
teaching it because it was taken by by
the folks in the committee who proposed
this and who look at this and the reason
for which this decision was taken notice
okay so I'm we talked about like if and
star force and that's not a pointer it's
not a pointer it's a it's there so the
fact that you star against the non
pointer is rather new but it's not the
new West because there is a type that
does that which is sed optional and
let's see the optional port design which
uses like o star means you know the
option is going to be the reference even
if it's not a pointer and then the you
know the folks came with the expected
proposal and they said oh wait a second
we have something that these are stars
in optional so we should be consistent
with the poor decision design decision
we made before so let's do that by the
way the proposal is still in flux so you
have the power to influence it right
your local politician yes sorry yes I
would have an implicit conversion so the
code is unmodified would be unmodified
for the happy case so not the happy
happy case you know to begin to put
stars and arrows every everywhere so
that's the problem so okay if you want
centralized or hanging I simply use star
result with you know this was my
personal opinion you may love it you
star result and that would be an int or
otherwise he's going to throw there so
all you need to do to your code again is
add those stars and arrows to your code
to make sure that the you're happy case
is handled properly right so with the
expected of the DNA we're going to have
an association between errors and
computational goals
so that's very nice it's an its new
traditional exceptions are tied to
functions you say well you know I have
this function that tries to do something
and may throw an exception and have this
other function that may try to something
else and throws another exception but
here this the grouping is different its
orthogonal if you wish in this case we
don't associate the exceptions with
functions but we associate exceptions
with results right so function is going
to return and expect it and then you
know the expected the expected itself
has meaning regardless of the function
that produced it it's going to be I'm
going to transport this information
around so I find that very interesting
because it's pretty much like with
mutexes and lox people sometimes
associate mutexes and lox with function
which is the wrong way to look at it
because you want to associate meat X and
lox with data that they protect yes I
hope everybody is at the Sundering yes
here I know this stadium is huge and
there's so many people here that maybe
they're not everybody hears me but yes
right yes mutexes go with the data they
protect us the association it's not with
like uncle if this function is gonna use
this mutex and this other function is
gonna use oh my god this other mutex no
please right it's the data
similarly expected would would associate
the error with the data that was
supposed to be there right and I like
that prop dislike my most significant
bit I like about about this idea awesome
so now we have a lot of advantages for
the small price so another thing is like
naturally we have multiple exceptions
active you know in C++ as there's rule
you can only have one exception in
flight except when you can you know I
suppose you can have multiple exceptions
flight in flight right you just can't
throw an exception when one is already
thrown but you can't throw from a catch
and catch it inside the catch and you
have two exceptions flying
right so with with this you can we have
an array of expected you can have you
know a map with whatever collection of
expected objects and some or all of them
may be exceptions no problem so you get
to collect a bunch of exceptions if you
want I won't recommend it necessarily
but it can so for each value that's
being that's supposed to be somewhere
you may also have the exception that
prevented it from being produced so
that's pretty awesome
you can switch at will between the style
of I want to healthier right now and I
want to simply use the value for the
happy case and if anything goes wrong
an exception is going to be thrown so
you can very naturally switch between
these two programming styles
teleportation if you wish is possible
across thread boundaries across no flow
subsystem boundaries you can even like
passes through a C API for a while as a
pointer and then back from the C API
into into years which is I can't heard
of with exceptions it's really difficult
you can teleport across time save the
exception now throw it later if you wish
etc so exceptions become commoditized
thanks for the follow alright right
commoditize so exceptions become as okay
as any other value to mess with right so
you can collect and group and combine
them anyway what do you wish awesome so
let's look at an implementation
well it's not stay here don't leave so
let's look at an implementation we have
a bit of code here so we have the
expected class as promised we it has two
parameters then it has a simple payload
it has a TA or a na and it has an okay
which is initialized to true because I'm
an optimistic person so by default I
assume that the object is good is nice
right so then the constructor the
default constructor of expected is going
to create a tea
address yay and this guy because it's
true is just gonna work right I don't
need to initialize it again make sense
so I'm initializing the T part and all
key is gonna be true by the way those
debate about this what is unexpected if
constructed implicitly from nothing
should it should we go for a glass half
full or for the glass half empty and the
obvious answer is they call it expected
what do you expect
right so I'm not sure why any people any
person would kind of even create that
argument so then we have the obvious you
know the usual suspects which would be
I'm going to create an expected from a
TM I'm copying it into and by the way so
you know those of you who already use
C++ sort of more recent version C++ you
know that for each of these functions
there's a hecatomb of of additional over
laws that in neutral for example for
this particular expected of consti and
person RHS you need to have what other
functions just for completeness you are
dedicated smart engineers yes no I mean
for this constructor that takes a con
Steve reference I would need to have
other very similar constructors that yes
that take the are very thank you that
take the are val reference to team right
and i need to have the methods that work
on temporary sometimes i don't think
that construction is actually defined
for constructing our values so probably
not but anyhow this is a this is um
what was the word distilled down version
of what you're gonna find online in the
implementation because the apprentice is
really like you can i there's a lot of
repetition in in the actual
implementation just to handle all the
cases the advantage being you have a lot
of generality because you get to
initials from any are valuable value
what what is their of type team
and now we get to this third overall
which is interesting I have a
constructor that takes a expected of
Const unexpected of e RHS and the
initialize is okay to false and it
generates a neat construction at the
address of nay now my question to you is
why do you think it was necessary to
take unexpected of V instead of E let me
kind of let me specify unexpected is
like a completely boring wrapper type it
does doesn't do anything at all all it
has it has a value member which is the
actual e object that's in there yes
please
excellent Thank You T could be e and
that's actually it can happen what if I
want to parse an integer and the error
code is also an integer right but wait
it gets worse what if I want to parse an
integer and error code is along and then
I have all the conversion nonsense going
on for me right what if I expect a
actually what if I expect an unexpected
you can't do that so unexpected is
specifically designed to be a pariah in
the normal values world I'm not kidding
that is I'm not kidding this is not a
joke don't laugh please ladies and
gentlemen so unexpected was particularly
designed to be distinguished a
distinguished type that you're not
supposed to ever expect okay and
therefore so actually does the
limitation in the proposal it says you
can't you can define expense of anything
except unexpected you can't expect the
unexpected
so did that movie with that name doesn't
work okay so very interesting right so
this unexpected is a wrapper that simply
is a tag type that you know gives a tag
on top of e to make sure it is
distinguished from from T nice now we
have this is again a sort of a one of
those usual suspects that we have
expected of some
type that may or may not be tea and is
going to be forwarded right and let's
see yeah these are interesting PP so
it's gonna get interesting at swap so
these functions are going to copy and
expect an internal order say is going to
simply initialize and they're going to
appropriately new this or new that
depending on the flag similarly there's
a move operator right so we're gonna
move from here and there's still moves
that move and just because I'm a bad
person
I wrote ok RHS okay I didn't say RHS
sequels move or voyages ok because I
know it's a boolean so move doesn't do
anything but believe me there are folks
right now in this room who believe he
shouldn't written as did he move that
guy is not a good guy he's not uniform
bad person so as I promised that it
comes to the operators that convert to a
tea and that would be the dereference
and again although it's not a pointer
it's going to work this way so the the
star praetor is going to be if not okay
gonna throw as promised and otherwise
you just simply return a value and then
we have the Const and our value
reciprocals that are implemented
similarly then I get to access the error
object and notice that error here is not
an unexpected of V is just the e so it's
it's undressed from the wrapper the
wrapper was necessary doing construction
only alright do I have a value so these
are sort of the usual suspects operator
bull as we discussed of value etc etc
etc these are not very difficult to
implement there's a very very
interesting practical primitive which is
value or what do you think it does
value underscore or yes Adi yeah it's
it's the exactly so if none expect the
expect that thing is not there
give me that you give me that value you
know it's on it's the default value so
it don't throw please just give me that
value right very nice so actually this
turns out to be practically very very
useful this would be the last function
we discuss which is also the most
interesting apologies for the expected
with a capital e here historical reasons
so we define the method swap and believe
me are not the first four lines are the
return type and also believe me or not
the return type is void it's a very
fancy way of writing void there and I'm
writing it this way actually I found a
bug in the proposal because you can't
actually swap any two expected values so
swapping is enabled if and only if T
would be a default North remove
constructible type which means I can
move on our value of type T to another T
without an exception and that is not for
whatever is an introspection primitive
in a standard library and something
named or may or may not know that
particular primitive is not
implementable in portable C++ you can't
sit down and write it on your own it's
it's supported by a primitive inside the
compiler which is underscore underscore
de braga right so in it you can't do it
it's an introspection thing that only
the compiler knows about it's not
accessible to regular C++ code I highly
recommend you look into this stuff you
know all of the all of the underscore T
things all of the ease this is that
because I believe introspection is
really the bee's knees
so we have there is no form of
constructive or constructive
constructive all T must be like that T
must be also swap of swappable but
possible possibly with a throw and he
must be also not remove constructible
and swappable let me explain why this is
and what happens here
so consider I want to swap this with RHS
so if I'm okay and the other guy is ok
easy I just want the yeas right
everybody's fair nice right fine that's
an easy case if I'm okay but the other
guy is not okay I'm going to defer by
swapping the order of arguments I'm
going to essentially punt on this case
it's gonna be handled down you see what
I'm doing here on the Earth's branch if
I'm okay and the other guy is not okay
let the other guy handle it so I this is
we use friends right because otherwise I
have to copy the Cinco twice all right
otherwise so on this branch here are not
okay I'm not okay if I'm not okay and
the other guys is also not okay I'm
swapping two inmates it's good to bad
people right swapna RHS Nate we're good
and here's where the demons come right
at the dot dot dot so under the Daisy
cases are understood we're good with AZ
cases these are sort of the obvious okay
so now I have the hard case in which one
is good and one is bad so let's see how
we swap a good person with a bad person
and make it fly well first we're going
to create a t object by means of a move
from nay remember I'm bad the other
guy's good so I'm going to create a
temporary by moving from nay so at this
point this is empty is a you know can
can receive another object but not
before actually destroying the II that's
there you know just for good form this
is almost are needed for most types but
it just to be like in keep with
everything with the law we're going to
simply say let me also call that the
structor against the object that has
been moved from notice that at this
point right here after the destructor
right here after this destructor call at
this point I committed to the
transaction already because I moved from
from the guy and if an exception happens
below this point that's bad
it means I lost irretrievably state so
we don't that's why the requirement at
the beginning the signature remember
they must be no throw move constructive
etc so we're gonna have okay let me now
create a new at the a which is now empty
I'm going to create a new by means of
moving from RHS yeh because the other
guy is good set the okay to true at this
point ok equals true at this point my
object this is good has received the
swap and now I don't need to go the same
about RHS all right Jesse a destroyed
the good guy and then move the move into
it from T and finally RHS ok gets true
false because it was a bad so this is
difficult and to wit it had bugs in the
in the initial implementation the
proposal and I find it very interesting
to think about and work on like you know
when do you commit to transactions what
is the minimum amount of moves and risk
you can take to make sure that this
transaction goes through I'm seeing
ominous looks from the organizers here
so we're gonna stop in a minute typical
years you'd say expect a double runtime
or whatever good equals 100 third start
good is 100 expected unexpected you know
the drill whenever you want to use it
there's a very nice helper function
which is also called unexpected which
constructs an unexpected object guess
what
right so this would be sort of simple
casual use of of expected great
so we centralized use you simply put
star everywhere whenever you want to
access anything you're going to use star
and you're good
an exception is going to be thrown and
you're good no problem
locally you can always test with if as
we discussed and you're just fine and
one other topic of debate is the last
topic gonna discuss is if an expected of
te sorry object is bad but nobody looks
at it is it should he throw or not
should he signal the exception or not so
I was I call the function didn't succeed
but I never look at the value should
anything happen no amazing leaders
debate about the still so I I agree that
now the tree in the forest philosophy
nothing you know if I don't care about
that valid and nothing should happen all
right
with this friends we're done thank you
very much and don't forget your favorite
color is green
thank you I'll be around here if you
have questions